Oh
you
I'm delighted to welcome all of you are
steam guests and colleagues to what is
now our third annual international
colloquium co-organized by the rial
collegial competency here at Harvard and
the Institute for ethics and
communication in organizations of
Valencia Spain and I'd also like at the
outset to recognize our co-sponsors
which include Valencia University
Bentley University the echo UNESCO chair
and the Abigail Adams Institute who
support made today's program possible
the convening title for today's panel is
developing trust and ethically healthy
organizations through humanistic
management those who have attended past
colloquia will recognize a strong
continuity with a theme of trust in the
first colloquium we examine sources of
trust in organizational environments and
we considered in particular what can
lead individuals to be trustworthy in
the second colloquium we examine
motivations beyond material
self-interest and asked how a variety of
higher purposes might be encouraged
harnessed and expressed in organizations
this year this key phrase it seems is
humanistic management a term that I'll
let our distinguished panelists define
but one that evokes some distinctive
challenges to organizational theory and
the suggestion I suppose at least some
current management management practices
might be inhumane or at least
impoverished this in turn raises a
question what are the standards by which
to assess the ethical health of
organizations and how can managerial
practices contribute to this health one
of the hopes of today's discussion and
we will devote the majority of our time
to discussion is that we can turn a
corner in business ethics debates that
so often focus on critiques and failures
or the superficial affirmation of values
or singular ethical choices there
certainly are
momentus ethical dilemmas at business
leaders face but these aren't always a
stuff of daily operations and when one
considers the more mundane questions of
ethics and management so much literature
characterizes problems rather than
solutions or simply pays lip service to
some additional values we of course know
there are limits to certain incentive
structures and contracts we know that
there are problems with various
strategies and priorities but can we
articulate a viable alternative a better
way forward ultimately are their
concrete practices that can enhance
rather than undermined the full
potential of those we work with and
those we work for the importance of
these questions is I think increasingly
clear for last four years on a personal
note I've had the privilege of working
with fellows of harvard's ethic Center
where they tasked there has been to
diagnose and address problems of what
we've called institutional corruption
and the centre's research lab has
produced some really fantastic
scholarship as well as a number of very
practical recommendations and tools for
reform however we quickly discovered
that talking about institutional
corruption requires some positive vision
of institutional integrity and
organizational purpose we also learned
how essential it is to engage
practitioners who understand the
challenges that organizations face from
the inside so today's colloquium aims to
address important issues in the theory
and practice of Management and we have a
wonderful group of academics and
business leaders to help us do so
you